been married for a long time a lot
longer than i've been married 26 years
26 years
so i feel like
describe to me at that point is the
pressure is it well i'll tell you it's
weird because it's been a long time but
i still get the feeling she's not quite
sold on me yeah you know really like
like just the wrong thing like a
misplaced burp is all it's going to take
and she's she's out of there i could
have used you on valentine's day to come
and and just slam it home so to speak
the thing about i watch the piece and
the thing about valentine's day is
guys
complain about it like oh i got to get
something they got it all wrong i i
thank god for valentine's day because
it's it's society pressuring you to do
something nice to do that which you
normally wouldn't do it's it's making
you every guy one day just just not be
the self-absorbed dick that we usually
are right yes you think it's helping us
yes it helps us that day because i do it
i give her the flowers
and the weird part is
is she you get credit for it yes she's
thankful
and i feel guilty i feel
you know i feel bad for her i feel like
saying look i'm glad you're happy but to
be honest i only got him because the
whole country told me to
she shouldn't be
appreciative that's like the irs seeing
your your tax payment on april 15th and
saying oh you shouldn't have done it
yes we do we have to
that was such a sweet sentiment yes you
need guys need
that day where they someone tells them
do something you know listen day we
should have we should have national
listen day just put you just there you
put the phone down and you're like tell
me about the flea market go ahead
compliment day it would be nice to think
oh how long how many years married me
it's been uh 12. and you know
compliments go a long way yeah you know
what goes a long way
um
not complimenting
at the wrong time because they don't my
wife doesn't forget this is true
26 years married
she keeps bringing she brings this up
whenever we have a discussion where she
doesn't like something she'll say you
didn't even tell me that i looked good
on our wedding day still brings that up
yeah i know
i someone a woman gasped yeah i heard a
gasp but here's my defense this is what
i said to her and this didn't help me
i said look that was our wedding day
on the day that i'm committing myself to
you
for the rest of my life
can't you assume i find you attractive
you know what this is the thing when you
get into clothes i find that to be a
difficult area like what when they come
to you and they say do you like what i'm
wearing i don't know i don't know if
you're like me i'm not good at clothes i
don't well i've learned that
you have to pretend you're good like
like my wife like you mean like she'll
say which outfit this one or this one
and it took me decades to figure out you
don't say i don't know
because that seems like you don't care
you just pick one and go strong just go
that one that one right there and you
know commit to it
because she'll think you care it's risky
because she may go
why yeah
[Laughter]
you're stuck then you got it because
you don't know you don't know i don't
even see the dress it's just pixelation
with my wife's head popping out
i don't see
what you got to do is stall you stall
enough and she'll tell you why she'll
say it's because of the lavender is it
because of lavender
of course yeah you lavender
lavender is good and even though you
don't even know i don't even you know
lavender 90 i think it's a color but it
could be a fabric right
i'm not sure